I just landed the new hair commercial
I'm so sorry was that offensive no no
that you can always hold me accountable
[Music]
I think your scarf today large do-rag
deconstructed hoodie whatever this is
this is just so fun
I love your accessory okay so for the
team outing we're gonna do baseball caps
is that cool with everybody I'm all
that's for good that's cool yeah okay
cool not just fund uh you know make sure
there's no it's our nightmare hi there
I'm Arya reporting live for Channel five
News local woman found skateboarding in
her hijab
hey what are you watching you have to
watch this what a story against all odds
she's overcome so much adversity and
it's a story you'll want to hear at
11:00 until then we're wishing her and
her family the very best as well as that
beautiful Rama D in season do you know
her
nope no still brave I was at the airport
and these two women wearing hijab they
were stopped by security
so I said like if you're gonna stop them
you have to search me too
yeah what what did they say when you
said that we were in the TSA line so
they're like you need to wait your turn
but I've been listen to podcasts and
like time is up but that isn't like
really apply but but yeah it's insane
okay it's great it's crazy
no yeah hey yeah yeah you are so
beautiful
thank you really appreciate that but
really
hey are you ain't so beautiful I love
how you like always match what do you
mean you know you do much thanks you're
welcome hey isn't it Ramadan
oh god I'm having such a bad hair day
I'm so sorry was that offensive no no
you sure yes I didn't mean to imply that
I have hair I like your job thank you
I just want to circle back I just want
to make sure like you're okay
I didn't mean that might the hair thing
was I know it's not I get it I get it
I love the weekend